this
is star talk cosmic queries edition
and i got my co-host chuck nice jack hey
neil
what's happening to have you chuck it's
nice to have you it's always a pleasure
to be here
so today we're going to talk about omua
mua o mua mua
is that a new disney film
what and i i only know about it from
just what i read i don't
think much beyond that about it so we
bring in one of our
experts at large of course we've got
natalie starkey natalie welcome back
to star trek hi neil hi chuck it's
really good to be back nice to see you
both again
and you're an expert on like stuff
that's not planets
in a solar system yeah i don't think
that's your characterization i know fair
enough about planets but yeah
i i i like comets and asteroids i like
the smaller bits and bobs of the solar
system
i mean the stuff that could render us
extinct one day maybe
but hopefully not if we know enough
about these things
so if there's a comet natalie headed
forward towards earth
that's that's not good for you if that
happens no that that wouldn't be great
but actually it would be
if we could divert it away from earth
and then get a sample of it and bring it
back for the scientists
who want to study these things then that
would be great wow so so you're you're
going beyond bruce willis you don't you
don't just want to save the earth you
want to get some science done while
you're doing it why not you know we
might as well
you know there's enough of us here doing
this science that i think uh yeah we
could learn an awful lot
um if we can actually go
while you save humanity and civilization
can you bring back a sample from my life
right exactly
it's a bit of a different movie it's a
different movie that's a completely
different movie
so natalie you you have the title of
cosmo chemist
yes i didn't even know you could have
that title and
how many other people know that that's
even a title or something to aspire to
who are inside and you know
i didn't know it was something you could
do when i was younger
i had no idea and i actually went
through my degrees which were in geology
and then ended up doing a phd um in
again in geo geochemistry essentially
looking at volcanoes old volcanoes in
the arctic
um and then it was doing after that when
i became kind of what i would consider a
proper scientist where i'm
working for money and i'm getting paid
to do science that i became a cosmic
chemist because i just turned my
geochemistry into studying rocks from
space
so i was looking at you know common
asteroid samples
you just said you got borders well you
know there's only so much you can do
with earth no no i absolutely love it
and volcanoes like my absolute passion
but um
yeah i when i saw this job advertised
that was working on samples from the
stardust mission which was a nasa
mission to collect samples from a comet
i was absolutely fascinated so it was a
steep learning curve for me because i'd
never studied asteroids or comets or
anything like that before
um but essentially the rocks are all the
same
you look at earth rocks you look at
space rocks they all contain the same
sort of minerals and the way that we
analyze them in the lab
is exactly the same we're just kind of
finding out different things about them
so and what so if they're all the same
then
what's the point like what why why
like you know we're in space just like
every other celestial body is in space
and
shucks very much we're all made of the
same stuff why are you studying
oh chuck that reminds me of uh it was
john stewart on his show
back when he did the daily show he says
nasa has
no was it yeah i think it was john
stewart
we we went to mars and we just
discovered water on mars
for a billion dollars we discovered what
comes out of my faucet
no it's true i mean one of the main
reasons that we always argue is that we
can't find out a lot about the solar
system that we're within
by studying our own planet so we can
study our own planet to find out
how kind of how it formed and what
happened over the last few billion years
but we actually can't go back in time
that well because we've got plate
tectonics so our surface is constantly
changing which means that
we've sort of lost that really old
history about our own planet whereas if
we go into space
but just to be clear when you say
constantly changing
you mean on a geologic time scale
definitely so i think right no plate
tectonics
there's no plate tectonics dragging
cities down into volcanic magma
right this is you're talking about a
slow process so i mean
listen there's always hope
i'm sorry i interrupted keep going fine
no exactly and that should be pointed
out because i
often think in kind of time scales of
millions if not billions of years
and that becomes normal to geologists
and people that work in space science so
but yeah exactly it's a very slow
process maybe the plates that we're
sitting on move maybe
one to maybe 10 centimeters per year if
they're going very quickly so it's a
very small
um a small amount that they're moving
and it's over a very long time scale but
over that time things change so
continents move and they get you know
taken down into the earth and and melted
essentially
and then we get new volcanoes producing
new land which wouldn't have been there
before
um but it's a problem because it means
if we want to go back four and a half
billion years to when our planet first
was born
and and became a planet it's very hard
to do that with the rocks
that we have on earth because they don't
really sample all of that history
but if we go to asteroids for example
they pretty much haven't changed since
they formed so they've gone through a
little bit of processing
but what we'll say is that they're
essentially the same as when they formed
four and a half billion years ago
so by studying them we can understand a
lot more about all the planets and
including earth and we can find out
things about you know even how life got
uh that's one of the ways that that we
can find out those answers so
so studying space rocks is really really
valuable and getting samples on earth is
also really valuable
so let me ask you let me ask you guys
chuck that that was a big
f.u okay to that question
i just want to make that clear
there's got to be some some reason that
makes sense uh
but speaking of that though um when you
look at this since we are constantly
having a makeover here on earth
uh and you're getting these snapshots
from these you know kind of frozen in
time
pieces that are out there when it comes
to those pieces of this for both of you
is most of that floating out there
asteroids these fragments are they
kind of like space uh to to use a word
like natalie is that space rubbish uh is
that
is that just trying to show you is that
is that is that is that
is that like the waste of what's left
over in formation
or is that um
the remnants of something
cataclysmic so it's a bit of everything
really
so it depends what's objects you know
wait natalie he just accused you of
studying rubbish
yes and some of it is essentially
it's the leftover building blocks of the
planet so many of the asteroids are the
same as the planets and this the same
objects as when they formed but the
planets have then
grown so large that they've undergone
their own processing so you take any of
the large rocky planets
they've all what we say differentiated
into layers because
they've got so big that they've melted
their insides and actually the you know
the iron
minerals have sunk to the middle of them
and the silicate the lighter minerals
are all on the outside making a crust
so they're they're very complicated
they've actually been processed a lot
whereas the asteroids are much smaller
so on the whole they didn't do that so
they're sort of the leftover building
blocks
and some but natalie we think of rocks
as being heavy yeah
and you're describing them as being
light floating to the top yeah
so please explain that so it's all
relative
um yeah yeah just
for those of you listening don't try to
go floating
with rocks that's all right that's true
yeah
that's how that's how to make sure the
body doesn't float back up
yeah exactly and it's one of the reasons
we're on the surface in fact
because you know you go to the center of
our planet which you can't do physically
but we know what's down there by
studying rocks from space and by using
geophysics and
and earthquakes to figure out what's
down there we know the center of our
planet is very dense it's made of iron
and nickel so it's very dense and heavy
and then as you
move outwards you get lighter and
lighter elements as you go and then you
eventually get to an atmosphere which is
obviously made of a very light elements
like oxygen and nitrogen and things like
that
now that happens on almost every planet
that you find
so there's definitely this kind of
relative gradation in terms of of the
density of the elements that you find
but when you go to the asteroids they
tend to be there are a few that have
differentiated and
made these layers but on the whole
they're smaller objects that didn't do
that so
they're the same all the way throughout
so if we sample them we can learn about
basically what is the average
composition of our planet if you were to
mix it all back together again
and take away those layers which is
really valuable because otherwise we
don't know what kind of our starting
composition is um it's almost like
taking
the cake taking the cake apart
essentially we're making a cake
we've got all these different
ingredients we can start to see what was
in the cake and we understand kind of
what we started with what were our
constituent ingredients which is really
important
okay so i got a question for you so
we discovered we you know the
astronomical community
discovered an object
named that
apparently came from outside of our
solar system and was passing through
so everything you just said
would give us no insight into that
object presumably because it's not from
this solar system
yeah so one of the great things about
space is that we think
well basically we have laws of physics
and we think we understand some of those
pretty well
and so we expect that if we go to
another star system outside of our solar
system
we expect things to be pretty similar
now we know that stars can differ
and therefore their temperatures and
their size is different the things that
that are around them the planets and the
objects that orbit around them could be
very different to what we have here
but we expect on the whole things to be
pretty similar wherever we go
so when we go to the very edge of our
solar system what we find there is the
comets which we haven't really spoken
about yet we've spoken about the
asteroids the rocky parts about
kind of the leftover building blocks of
the planets but when you go to the
comets
they're very light these are usually
made of very light elements but
they do contain rock dust but they also
contain a lot of ice in them
which could be water ice it might be
carbon dioxide ice all sorts of
different types of ices
so carbon dioxide ice we're familiar
with that as dry ice
people we'll call it that yeah all sorts
of things down there so we've got lots
of cold materials because um these
objects are really really far from the
sun in fact some of them
are so far from the sun we've never seen
them they're in the supposed alt cloud
which is a hypothetical thing
because we've never seen it but we think
that there must be a lot of icy objects
out there which are
probably quite small we don't think
there's anything the size of a planet
out there because we haven't seen it yet
and we probably should have if there was
something very large
out there but on the whole these objects
are quite small quite cold
and they formed basically at the start
of the solar system they they formed as
soon as the sun formed and they're
basically a part of this cloud that the
sun formed from
um a little sample of of an interstellar
cloud essentially
now these things are very loosely
gravitationally
bound to our sun because they're so far
away so what can happen with these
objects
is that sometimes they actually get
ejected from the solar system
and this is one option for what a
muammar might be it might be a rogue
comet from another
planetary exoplanetary system um that's
been basically
knocked out of its orbit sitting far
away from its sun
and it just kind of got thrown into the
hinterlands of interstellar space
and lost and not bound to any star
gravitationally and so just starts
you know traveling through interstellar
space forever and ever and ever
until it maybe passes through another
solar system without even realizing that
solar system's
there wow so it's basically
a vagabond yeah yes that's
cool yeah and so and this is made
possible because at the outer reaches of
the solar system
the sun's gravitational grip is only
very slight
on these objects so it wouldn't take
much to dislodge one
from the grip exactly it can be
dislodged by a passing planet so
in our solar system uranus or neptune
can pass
as they orbit around the sun they can
pass these objects and literally just
push them out gravitationally
or actually within the galaxy a passing
star coming
passing by our solar system and can
actually gravitationally pull these
objects away they're just so
so far from the sun that they really
aren't held on very well they're really
loosely within our solar system at all
now we're going to take a break in a
couple of minutes before we get to the
the cosmic queries part of this
but tell me how uh how about
got named so it was spotted actually
almost by chance and by a a telescope in
hawaii
called pan stars it's got really
complicated uh acronym and i can't
remember what it stands for i never can
um it's a really complicated one but
anyway it found uh it
basically by chance found this this
object out but just just to be clear
pan stars is the acronym not no exactly
no pan stars is the telescope acronym
so um because it was found by a hawaiian
telescope they thought they would give
it a hawaiian name
and i think oh is is the first part of
it which means
uh loosely means scout or messenger in
in hawaiian
and then the muammar means kind of like
a visitor from
from the distant past so it's kind of
giving us that so it's here
it's here doing reconnaissance
oh i get it this is
exactly what it is it's supposed to be
named right this is nothing more than an
alien reconnaissance mission checking us
out okay
built into the name right so very cool
and
is that does that have to be officially
uh um
uh accepted by the the nomenclature
committees of the
yeah so that's not its official name
it's a much friendlier name but we tend
to give
um any object in the solar system or
anywhere
we tend to give it a kind of a code name
which would tend to be used in papers
and scientific papers that are published
so
that's actually quite an interesting
story because it's had its kind of
proper name changed a few times because
originally it was thought to be a comet
so it had a c
title and then it became an asteroid so
it became an a title
and then the scientists decided it came
from interstellar space
and so it became an eye title with and
then the
the year after it so basically you know
when it was discovered
so it's gone through some name changes
but it's now currently um got an i
in its name well just to be clear it
would be the first i
it is so it's i one in fact so uh
c1 to c2 c3 however many have been found
and then we
won one but there is a number two wow
there is a number two we will get we
will think about that
after the break we're going to take a
break from star talk cosmic queries
we've got natalie starkey our
solar system comet expert who with us uh
who's answering all our questions about
the solar system it's vagabonds and
especially we'll be right back
we're back star talk cosmic queries the
amuamua
edition and i've got natalie starkey
here a friend
of star talks she actually is the author
of our
current space show at the hayden
planetarium the theater is closed
obviously during the covert shutdown but
when we reopen
uh you're all invited to come and check
it out and natalie
you've also written a book
catching stardust beautiful title i love
it
uh came out a year and a half ago or so
two years ago
and was that did that book sort of
capture your whole sort of research life
studying this the the comet dust from
the stardust mission it did yeah so
my inspiration was the stardust mission
because i've always been fascinated by
it and it was the first mission to
collect a comet sample comet samples in
space and bring them back to earth
and but then i also faced an awful on
the rosetta mission which was a european
mission which didn't collect samples but
what they did instead
was put a laboratory onto the side of a
comet instead so
that was kind of the next best thing
they would have liked to have brought
back samples but it's really expensive
to do that and
technically quite challenging we're
starting to do it now with asteroids
quite a few times
with osiris-rex and the high boost
emissions but you know this was a few
years ago now so
um the best we could do was literally
put a little landing laboratory on the
side and do some experiments
on the comet which is just fascinating
to me so you're actually landing on
these
places right yeah yeah it reminds me i
saw this comic
where there was some rover that went to
mars and
there are these aliens standing on mars
but they kind of all look like native
americans right and they say
there goes the neighborhood the colonies
come back
[Laughter]
but anyhow and natalie you you have a
title let me get this correct the
officer for outreach and public
engagement
at the open university in the uk
so so that means anytime we
call you you have to show up yeah it's
my job
because it's in your title yeah yeah
outreach public engagement so i'm just
going to hold you to that
yeah that's kind of that's i i would i
would get them to change that because
it's almost like being like my name is
chuck nice
and so like it's very difficult to be
like
you know an ass because people are like
because the moment
because the moment i have a bad day
people are like i know he wasn't nice i
know i know i know
you're out you know so now like you have
to engage people you have to
you have to i do and i love doing it as
well and so that's why
a few years ago i did give up uh
full-time science research because
i found that actually i just love it's
talking to people about this stuff
and it's it's always fascinated me and
i've written now my second book on space
science and
it's just what i love doing and i hope
that that comes with that book come out
no it'll be out in september 2021 so um
okay so we'll get you back on yeah that
would be great it's about space
volcanoes
so um yeah oh i love that and there's no
book on that
there are at the moment no there's um so
no it's going to be
and you have ice volcanoes in there so
it's fire and ice it's called so i focus
on
the hot volcanoes and then all the cold
volcanoes as well so now the volcano is
actually on a planet it's just not a
volcano floating through
space vagabond okay
because you know i thought it might have
been like a movement just you know just
just floating through cosmos spewing out
stuff that would be so weird that would
be
a science fiction stories um
embarrassing fact because they think
volcanoes just
they're not actually connected to
anything below
this would be a profound ignorance of
geophysics if there's just a volcano
right like like a look like a cosmic
locomotive
it would not stop from from its opening
chuck we we solicited questions on about
omua so what's
from our fan base are these patreons
and i'll definitely start with them yes
we will always start with patreon and i
think most of these questions are from
our patreon patrons well let's do it and
so let's get right into it
and uh let's see here this is curtis
lee saddle hack maybe
and he says maybe that's his name
uh he says he says given the extreme
rarity of objects zipping through our
solar system
even when those objects are homegrown
asteroids or comets
what is the likelihood of another object
like a muammua passing through
in the lifetime of anyone old enough to
remember
this recent event so uh
what kind of frequency would we see
could we see more of this or
and is anybody looking for us so that
one if they
do what guarantee do we have that we
would spot everyone that comes through
as an interloper yeah
maybe we've already missed like 10 of
them right right i mean for sure we've
missed
probably quite a few it's it's very
unlikely that this is the first object
to have gone to our solar system from
another star
so we don't know for sure because
obviously we haven't been looking for
that long so the pan stars telescope
that spotted this one
as i said in the last segment it wasn't
actually looking for it it's looking for
near-earth asteroids
so it's part of our kind of defense
system of looking about what's out there
around
our planet and what are the objects that
are close to us
in terms of asteroids and comets that
might pose a risk to us in the future
now it doesn't look at all of the sky
all the time it can't do that it's not
designed to do that so it looks at
portions of the sky at different times
so
there's a really high chance that it
could just miss one of these objects
completely
but over the course of time the objects
that within our solar system it should
spot all of them because it kind of goes
around and goes around again and looks
at different portions of sky
but obviously something just flying
through randomly that we're not
expecting and
isn't on an orbit around our sun it's
much easier to miss
plus natalie plus uh most of these
objects you're describing
are in the plane of the solar system so
if you're going to design a search to
get the most of them
you're going to stick to the plane so if
some some coming from above or below
you don't have as good of sky coverage
there do you that's very true
and actually we do some of the comets
within our own solar system don't
come along that what we call the
ecliptic plane of the solar system the
one that
basically all the planets are on um so
all the asteroids should do
um but some of the many of the comets
what we call the long period comets
which are these ones in the awk cloud
which sit in basically a cloud around
the solar system so you have the plane
of the planets and then you've got this
kind of shell
of comet icy objects which are comets
basically
and when those come into the inner solar
system and go via the sun
they can come in from all very different
random angles and then
can be going quite fast um so we do spot
those as well
um but the objects that are coming from
interstellar space
can come from literally anywhere and
they're traveling very very quickly
in relation to the objects that are
within our solar system so
that's kind of the first thing the first
piece of evidence that we go oh hold on
a
minute
we don't think this is from our solar
system it's going far too quickly
it can't have been sped up by
interacting with a large planet like
jupiter it's just going far too quickly
for that
in fact um was going so quickly that it
didn't even
it didn't even care our sun was there
our sun is massive it has a huge amount
of gravity
but um just passed straight by it and it
didn't even get kind of pulled in
towards it
um so you know it didn't care it was
going so quickly and
it was just chance that we spotted it so
so it did bend a little bit just not so
much at all yeah it wasn't going to get
like
like it took a look and then kept going
so it was on basically a
hyperbolic orbit so it's um and it had
excess hyperbolic velocity so it wasn't
going to get
captured by our sun as you know our
comets and asteroids are
but spotting other ones we just don't
know because the problem is we don't
understand how many objects are lost
from a solar system like
ours or from other star systems outside
in the galaxy
we don't how much material is thrown out
into interstellar space
and we've started to make models that
kind of kind of guess at these numbers
or the volume of material the size of
material for example you might get
comets
pulled off and sent out into
interstellar space you might get a
planet being disrupted and broken apart
by interaction with another planet or
something and they can get thrown out
but we just don't know how much is out
there so so
how many how many eye objects do we have
we've had two so we've got
a movement which is number one and then
there was one called 2i borisov
which was spotted i think in 2019 or
2018
um and that that's the second one so
that is thought to be
a comet um but again it's an
interstellar object so we've got
two now that i know of two in a couple
of years oh wow we're
we are on a roll so
you said the second one was a comet now
how do you differentiate between a comet
from our
orc cloud or just you know out there
past the you know hanging around our
solar system
and an interstellar is it from the way
it comes in or is
what are the determining determining
chuck she just spent
10 minutes explaining it very well it's
on a hyperbolic orbit
oh okay yeah well i was it has a speed
that is unlike anything that
in orbit around the sun would give you
gotcha so that's it all right and and
and so now here's the question nothing
else can we give you gonna help you out
chuck i'll help you out on this okay
okay pretend chuck asked this question
right if the object is at such distance
from us how do you know whether it's a
comet or an asteroid
okay so what are the things that
scientists look for when they first
spotted this object was they got
as soon as they found out they'd seen it
on panel stars they were like we need to
get some other telescopes looking at it
to try and just find out a little bit
more about it it was already at this
point
moving away from the sun so it was
getting further and further away from us
so we had to do
be really quick because it's getting
dimmer faster exactly and it's already
quite a small object we think
it's a maximum of maybe a thousand
meters long
um and maybe a hundred or so meters wide
so first of all it's quite a weird shape
but we can come back to that but it is
quite small so trying to see these
things is tricky and it's not very
bright
so trying to see anything dark in space
is always tricky it needs to reflect the
sun
or produce its own light for us to see
it now the way it can become brighter
is um if it starts to produce activity
off its surface now we would expect that
from a comet
because i explained earlier that we we
have the comets in the outer solar
system
they're very icy they're made up of lots
of different types of ice now when you
bring ice close to something hot it's
either going to melt or if you bring up
something really really hot
it's going to sublimate so it's going to
turn straight to gas so the
the ice in a comet when it gets close to
the sun starts to stream off the surface
producing a gaseous kind of envelope
around the
the nucleus the rocky part of the comet
and also brings off dust particles with
it so you can see this stuff
really quite easily with telescopes so
the object basically gets bigger
it it's its ability to reflect light yes
as all this yeah as as this cloud around
it grows
yeah so it appears larger and we we see
it because it's kind of glowing for us
so we'll see that activity now
um didn't produce any cometary style
activity
um that we could see anyway now it's the
problem is that we wouldn't necessarily
see it because it was getting very far
away
i think um borisov the other one did
produce cometary activity when it went
close to the sun so we could then tell
that it was
probably had some ices somewhere within
its structure
and therefore it was probably a rogue
comic from another star system
um but yeah for a moon builder we didn't
see that activity which doesn't mean it
isn't there
it just means we couldn't see it below
the detection limits as you know
as as is typically reported in a
scientific paper exactly
yeah it's never this isn't or this is
it's the evidence show
supports that it isn't or the evidence
supports that exactly
okay all right chuck give me another
question all right here we go this is
philip dewind he says uh is there any
evidence that there's
more objects coming our way or
i mean you kind of just said that you
know we really don't know but
is there any evidence right now well
let's ask it another way did both of
these come from the same same place yeah
oh that's a good question cause i don't
actually know the answer to that one i
don't know where
the second one actually came from i know
a lot more about
mal we only know that it came from a
certain region
of the galaxy but it's hard to we don't
know exactly where it came from because
when we try and backtrack that in time
we don't know how long it's been
traveling
and the galaxy moves during that time it
could have been up there for 50 million
years traveling through space or even
longer
so we don't know exactly where it's come
from we can't pinpoint it to a
particular star for example
because the galaxy rotates the farther
back in time
you want to trace it the more you have
to sort of unscramble what the galaxy
had been doing to have any sense of
where it was exactly
50 million years ago or 100 million
years yeah and then we don't know when
it was ejected if it came from another
star system we don't know when it was
ejected
um so trying to work back where it came
from is you know almost impossible
and it takes about 200 million years for
the galaxy to make one full rotation
so anything that is you think has been
in space that long
then it could not have possibly come
from where you think
because the whole galaxy did a whole
uh rotation so yeah it's very likely
that more of these
style of objects are going to pass
through our solar system they probably
have been for eons ever since you know
the solar system formed
equally some of the objects from our
solar system will be out there doing the
same thing when you think even about
just the voyager spacecraft now they're
just going to go out into space now and
continue on and if there's any
aliens out there on other planets and
other star systems in the future they
may then see those spacecraft and go oh
what is it is it quiet an asteroid or oh
it's an alien species no it's vegeta
oh it's vegeta wow
if people saw the movie but so chuck
here's the good story
that we're missing here is maybe there
was a destroyed solar system and all the
debris came towards us right and we can
just get the pieces and reassemble their
monuments and temples
oh look at that cosmic lego
i've been thinking a lot of times with
lego set that would be great
yeah with homeschooling i'm mostly just
doing exercise and lego
so this is great
all right chuck one more question before
we take the next break all right here is
cameron bishop says i was wondering
could objects like a more more be great
opportunities to study the idea of
panspermia
um uh how would panspermia
unfold without destroying the genetic
material on
impact not of a muammu because they're
not that's not an im that's not gonna
impact but
if we were to uh have have an object
that
would would impact us how would we be
able to study it like that
just to put this in context the two
levels of panspermia you can imagine one
of them is
life moving from planet to planet within
a solar system
right and then asking whether there's
enough sort of forces
operating to get life from one star
system to another in the galaxy
so i think this question is going to to
the sort of the the limiting case on
that
right now what do you have to say about
that so yeah it's going to be tricky
first of all
we didn't get to study this particular
object enough for long enough to even
have any idea what it's made of we
really don't know if it's metal or rock
or really what it's made of so
in terms of seeing whether it contains
carbon or any other kind of organic
molecules on there we have no idea
in the future if we had enough notice
that one was coming and we could study
in more detail we would definitely need
to put a mission up there
to sample some of it because we're not
going to get the answer just by looking
at it with telescopes so it's it's pie
in the sky really
it's not a question we're going to be
answering anytime soon we're trying to
do that
kind of science with asteroids and
comets within our own solar system
um and that's kind of the level that
we're at we're trying to get up there
and see what they contain do they
contain the building blocks for life et
cetera et cetera so
it's a long way off but it is a good
question because we have no idea
obviously we have no idea if we're alone
in in the solar system or in the galaxy
on the universe so
yeah it's it's one way that we could
start to think about that in the future
wait wait but there's another half of
that question which is uh and i'll
i'll juice up the question just further
to get your answer
if in fact we do learn that one of these
objects has not only organic molecules
but like the building blocks
you know amino acids and and maybe even
some life form on it panspermia requires
that that has an encounter with a planet
and then that planet gets seeded will
any of those molecules
and and and early life forms possibly
survive
such an impact i mean it's unlikely
particularly for an object
going through interstellar space first
of all it's going to be subject to
really high levels of radiation and the
temperatures are just
crazy but okay so if something could
survive for that long on
a small object which i think is very
unlikely
then if it would collide with another
object that would probably be quite a
devastating collision
for both parties involved so i think
it's unlikely
after billions of miles
in interstellar space at absolute zero
close to it
and then all the radiation you're
talking about let me tell you something
i'm not giving up from no fender bender
when i crash into a planet my response
is
that's all you got this is home i'm home
right so clearly the atoms survive
the collision so if there were organic
molecules that carbon and nitrogen
and silicon and all the rest of whatever
we need then
those molecules could be broken apart
but nonetheless you can still think of
these objects as
as feeding the chemical elements
necessary for life mm-hmm yeah
prometheus
yeah definitely we need we need all
those basic elements to
to make the building blocks for carbon
molecules and organic
matter but it's a big step and we we you
know we have a lot of that matter
everywhere but we it's
oh my god now i want to ask now i got to
ask but i know we got to
end so i'll wait i gotta we're gonna
take a quick break but all right
put it on the table and we'll see go all
right here it is so based on what you
just said
and you talk about comments uh is there
a way like a comic could come in
and just as it instead of burning up in
the atmosphere
it just deposits what it is
across like you know our atmosphere
almost like
you know seeding but not necessarily so
when we come back commercial we will
find
me take a quick break uh star talk
cosmic queries with natalie starkey
star talk cosmic queries edition
the interloper from outer space
interstellar space i got cosmo chemist
natalie starkey
always good to have you natalie and
natalie do you um
do you have a twitter handle you can
share i do it's at starkey stardust
okay wow not only are you a cosmo
chemist which sounds like
the space version of breaking bad but
then
but then you get starkey stardust on top
of that
oh man that's good stuff good stuff okay
and chuck's handle is chuck nice comic
yeah exactly
so inventive so we left off
we last left off uh wondering you
you asked the question chuck yeah that
if
a comet can come in and it has the
ingredients for life
right instead of colliding with earth
and burning up can it just sort of break
up in the atmosphere
and then sprinkle down gently and
but the problem here chuck is the matter
of the kinetic energy it has
that energy has to go somewhere
somebody's got to eat that kinetic
energy and if it hits the atmosphere or
the ground all that kinetic energy goes
back into the object
and it destroys every freaking molecule
however
natalie's stardust mission managed to
collect
comet particles with a fast-moving
object
so natalie what magic did you guys
perform on this mission so that you
didn't
you didn't destroy the very thing you
tried to yeah i mean i can't take any
credit for i just got to analyze some of
the particles that were connected but
nasa did an amazing amount of work and
their scientists worked on
um some material called aerogel which is
a basically a very
not very dense material which made
mostly made of silica it's all made of
silica
and it slows down the particles as
they're captured so
it was made into like blocks on this
kind of tennis stack tennis racquet
style collector
and so it literally flew through the
tail of the comet particles from the
comet hit this collector
and they were rapidly decelerated and
but the important part when you do that
is
not to let the particles heat up so this
material actually
took the heat away from those particles
as they impacted and preserved them
really really beautifully in fact even
the really kind of
volatile stuff like the the organic
matter which should have kind of
gotten kind of evaporated away
essentially okay so natalie what you're
suggesting is
if we replace earth's atmosphere with
aerogel
then we'd be able to collect anything
that fell in there you go
chuck let's see if we can do a lightning
round see how many of these questions we
can get in
all right okay let's see this is
tony hamm who says could it have gotten
the shape due to the possible
gravitational pull of planets and stars
so
you know we didn't talk about the shape
but it's well she gave the dimensions
it's very it's like a cigar shaped cigar
yeah yes it's basically we're not
exactly sure
it's hard to know the shape because we
can't see it directly and
so one of the we think it's probably
quite long it's possibly five to ten
times
longer than it is wide which is really
unusual shape we've got we've seen
nothing like that in our solar system
um and if it was over five times longer
than its width then it's a really weird
shape so it's very hard to describe how
that would have come
from a comet or an asteroid or another
planet it is
extremely strange it might not be cigar
shaped some people think it might be
kind of
flat almost like a disk shape so it's
basically quite long in relation to how
wide it is
which is odd but why can't like title
forces have stretched it out
like for example in uh comet shoemaker
levy back 20 years ago
uh 25 years ago that was one comet
broken into many
pieces if you couldn't resolve the
different pieces and you step back you
might think it's just one long elongated
comment
potentially but they're all basically
rotating at the same time so that they
would be bound in some way because we
use light curve data which is used in
astronomy all the time to look at
objects outside of
of our earth and you know stars and
planets and things the way we do this is
we look at how it reflects the light how
an object reflects
the sunlight or whatever it might be the
star near it
and what it's got a very odd light curve
shape
and so basically it looks like this
object is essentially tumbling through
space
normally an asteroid or a comet would
just rotate very almost very neatly and
very predictably
um but this is basically tumbling it's
it's really really odd
so i think it's got to be one object
because if it was a lot of objects you
probably wouldn't expect to see that and
that pattern in the light
happening coherently yeah okay that was
a good answer but it was not a lightning
round oh sorry
we'll try it we'll try better next time
i'm gonna put you on notice
okay chuck give me another so there are
a lot of people who think that this
might be some type of
alien uh technology or
some kind of masked alien craft
philip n i says
is this from another civilization
yeah no it's really exciting that um
when this was suggested it is a really
exciting prospect but
we've got to remember i love the old
carl sagan saying extraordinary claims
require extraordinary evidence
um and we don't have the evidence to
really strongly support the idea that
this is an alien spatial or some alien
spaceship junk or something like that
what we have to do first is rule out all
the more natural
observations that we've made all the
more actual ideas about what this thing
could be
but just to be clear your statement we
have to rule them out
is a in a way a scientific bias against
it being aliens yes right to say we have
to rule out
these other explanations before we
accept the aliens
that's uh let me not call it a bias it's
the history of this exercise shows that
that's the right thing
and we have to apply razor we have to go
with the simplest explanation first
because it's usually the correct one
but once we've ruled out the more simple
explanations that it's a comet or an
asteroid or a piece of a
broken piece of a planet from another
exoplanet then we can start to look at
the more obscure things like is it a
piece of an alien spaceship or something
but what was the most compelling
evidence to even think this at all
um i think the fact its shape is
probably one of the hardest things to
describe
um but having said that we don't really
understand its shape very well as i said
we don't know its exact dimensions i
remember reading that it's
its trajectory through the solar system
was behaving in ways that sort of
newton's law of gravity
would not have predicted is that still
holding up that those observations
um so yeah it basically was speeding up
um as it went by the sun but it was not
because of gravity from the sun now
objects normally speed up as they go
towards the sun
and because of its gravity but this it
wasn't happening because of gravity so
we have to explain
why it was speeding up and how it got
this kind of
more basically more velocity as it went
by the sun that wasn't geography duh
it's aliens there you go of course so
that that is a hard one to explain
scientists are looking at that
they turned on the impulse engines
that's exactly
right so this this little engine that
could have inside it could be jets uh
basically of comet comic jets coming off
you just said it's not a comment
you said that's the problem we don't we
can't rule it out so i think that's what
we've got to stick with simple
explanations first and we've got a lot
more work to do we're not going to do it
on this comment or this object sorry
um because it's gone now and we're never
going to see it again okay
if i could recap what you just said it's
you want to rule out every possible
natural explanation
and even when you've ruled them all out
are you compelled to say that it's alien
or might you say i'm not clever enough
to figure out
what missing natural explanation i've
yet to
yeah i think that i think the latter
because it's even like you know when we
found
we thought we found life in the
atmosphere of venus like
the scientists had to work so hard to
rule out all the natural things that
could have been and all the natural
all the other other natural things and
then they said it could be life but
they still weren't sure and so they put
that out there and said it could be
but i think we can never say for sure of
course the press eats it up
and that's always the problem with
making these claims that you've got to
be really
careful because then they're
misconstrued by by the media question
listen natalie i just need you to rule
out
11 799
reasons so that we can get to aliens
i'm just saying we're all scientists
here how do we get to aliens
[Laughter]
that's a famous number now right 11 799
there you go
oh by the way to future people 20 years
from now who are listening to this
podcast
just go back and read the news from
january to 2021
and then you'll know where that number
comes from and who chuck
who opened the time capsule the
invitation is so bad you won't know but
if you
if you look up the op you'll get it
anyway um
that's it all right yeah i'm sure that's
it chocolate yeah whatever i'm making it
it is now damn it it is not what's your
name now
e capianas is it usual for an asteroid
to have a cylindrical shape what is the
shape of an asteroid great question
basically it depends on size and now
we've gone out to the solar system and
started looking at more of these objects
we found they can be
loads of different shapes and sizes so
they tend to be
sort of round they tend to approximate
around shape
but they're not always the smaller ones
can definitely be sort of any shape you
like but
they're gonna they're not we've not seen
anything like this before
so it is really really unusual and it is
hard to explain
um with natural processes but we need to
figure out some more stuff so yeah
so what you're saying is asteroids have
the greatest sort of variation in shape
and among the high variations in shapes
that you have seen
and measured this falls outside of that
high variation yeah
it's definitely at the the upper end so
i know what it is it was a
it was a vertical plug in the throat of
a volcano
and it shot out okay and it was actually
a weapon coming through space
and so the volcanoes and space movie
will now has a new way it can have a
tactical
i like that one i
like that one
well natalie we'll we'll look forward to
your next book coming out in the fall of
2021
and a catching stardust uh it's a it's a
it's quite
the the story that i think everyone
should know about
and who publishes that spy balloon
i remembered that that's right i
remember that correctly okay
uh excellent natalie always good to have
you thanks for dialing in from the uk
thanks for having me and homeschooling
your four-year-old
so yeah continue i'll do my best another
three months to go
excellent excellent all right guys uh
thank you again
natalie and chuck this has been star
talk on mcquarries
i'm your host neil degrasse tyson your
personal astrophysicist as always to
keep picking up